thank you so hi everybody and thank you
very much for attending my talk I'll be
speaking today about how to teach models
help us perhaps make some decisions on
interior design questions and first yeah
maybe a few more words about myself so I
work as a data scientist at two books
this is a Poland based company in Europe
and I was born in Lavinia which is
actually even a smaller country in
Europe and it is mainly known for
basketball and sadly not much else and I
have a background in mathematics now
doing my PhD in machine learning and
also as mentioned in my free time I work
as a concert photographer and those two
things mathematics and photography led
me to computer vision and machine
learning so first of all how do we
perform search and interior design and
what is the problem here so I don't know
how about you but I don't usually buy
any stylish designer furnitures and even
if I did I would have no idea what other
furnitures to put that with any tables
or sofas or how could I design my room
so that everything looks nice and fancy
and stylish so the question here is
really not to find items that are
similar visually so let's say find items
that are in the same color on the same
shape but we also want to find items
that share some statistical similarities
and sometimes we also want to extend our
query with textual input so let's say we
have bought this marble called table or
we got it as a gift because we would
never buy such thing and then we are
looking for a chair so we have a text
query chair or maybe a friend of ours
really liked the table and he wants to
buy a similar one but in different color
so then he wants to add a text where you
were just describing a different
oh and this problem is actually kind of
difficult because if we applied a
regular visual search to the image which
we let's say found in the catalog then
the similar is simple visual search
engines such as Google Images would
Yildiz with different pictures also with
living rooms also there are some sofas
dining table maybe they have some color
scheme that is similar to ours so we
could not argue that those images are
not similar to our query image but
sometimes this is just not what we are
looking for so how to make the engine
find items let's find this particular
item which is this table and not look
for the items in the background and also
to find other items for the same style
in real life how is this style search
actually applied should we should we do
that should we should we waste our time
doing this and especially for fashion
this is done already quite a lot so such
ecommerce Giants as a saucer zalando are
applying visual search by allowing users
to snap outfits on the street to upload
any custom images to find similar items
in their database of clothing items so
this is for example down at ASIS or
solando and also for interior design I
am not aware of any bigger solutions but
for example Pinterest is using visual
search a lot and it's using for all
kinds of items actually this is the
Pinterest lenses which was introduced I
know in like last year and it was
introduced only in States so I'm not
sure how it worked did it work well it's
you know better definitely and and here
so how do we do this style search so
what we've developed as an internal app
is is allowing you to choose designs
from a catalogue of images and then to
I'm the this exact item similar on the
picture or different similar items in
the database or just matching items
which are from different categories as
well as just to snap a picture and then
find that particular item in our
database so actually this is not a huge
database this is this was collected from
IKEA website and a short disclaimer here
we okay I didn't pay us a dime for that
so so yeah if anybody of you is working
for IKEA we can discuss later and yeah
this is only two thousand images and the
idea behind our model is if we cannot
define style similarity as this is a
very subjective measure we could not ask
many people well even if we ask a lot of
laborers to say if two items are on the
same style or not then we would
definitely get a lot of problems that
this is subjective so a lot of people
would have different opinions on whether
those two items are similar or not and
we would have to collect a lot a lot of
data to be able to normalize so yes
indeed we need some measure that could
allow us to save other two items as
similar or not and one of the ideas that
we followed is that we could use
contacts so if we have this picture from
catalogue magazine well this one is from
Ikea website but they also have some
inspirations there and we just assume
that this is nicely designed room so why
not go one step further and assume that
all those objects that are present in
the picture they at least have a high
probability of sharing the same
statistical statistical properties so
what do we did we collected three types
of data from their website one of them
was room images so those nicely styled
some room pictures but also we needed
catalog photos of those of the same
objects present on white background
nicely lit with some descriptions
available to them
as a first step in our stealth search
engine we applied object detection
because of course when a user snaps a
photo or it has a lot of background
which we don't really need so what we
want is to be able to extract some
regions of interest to be able to find
different kinds of objects present on
that so that without any prior
information out what kind of object it
is without any tags so that is a sulfur
chair dining table we repeat we are able
to automatically determine what kind of
objects there are and then later on only
use to those parts of the image that are
responsible for those objects and to do
object detection we actually tested a
few frameworks the first one has this
cool name
Yano 9000 which stands for you only look
once and this is a nice framework which
is very fast it assumes that so it does
end to end training and prediction at
the same time it gives you bounding
boxes with confidence level for for
objects present in this grid element and
at the same time it predicts class
probability so it's not doing it's a two
step wise so it's not as an usual object
detection manner doing first region
proposals than predicting different
classes for those bounding boxes but
it's doing two tasks at the same time
and in the end it presents you with a
set of final detection the network
itself very textured a compass comprised
of 19 convolutional neural convolutional
blocks and it was written in C that's
why it's very fast to use I want
compared two different models
urug I'm not sure about right now but a
year ago it was it really surpassed the
state-of-the-art it changes a lot so I'm
not sure which of the detection
framework is state of the writer out
right now but to be able to do it
use it in our Python framework we
actually had to do a simple Python
wrapper so this is just a nice example
that is very easily done with c-types we
just needed kinds of arguments type of
result and then we were able to wrap an
example function here so we wrapped a
bunch of functions from their framework
and then we were able to use it in our
object detection also we tested a
different object detection framework
which was released later later this year
Google tensorflow actually released
their API for object detection and it
had a lot of free training models that
are actually very easy to use they work
out of the box they are portrayed on
khakha data set so the data set which
already has more than 80 categories of
different object classes and it is also
quite easy to find unit on your own data
set so from the available models we
tested a few and with chosen faster air
CNN this is also and to end object
detection framework and it first
proposes it generates region proposals
and then by pulling regions of interest
it's it does the final classifier and
after we've done the first step of
detecting different objects and
determining the kind of class the object
is we do visual search so here we
actually follow the standard procedure
which is to extract visual features from
a pre trained convolutional neural
network so this is a very popular way of
doing transfer learning we take we take
a network which was learned to classify
objects to different classes like CAD
dark airplane chair and then as we are
not interested in classifying this
picture but only to be able to generate
some vector in n dimensional space we
are taking the the second to last layer
of the
pre-trained Network and we say that okay
this is the representation of our item
and we do this for all the objects in
the database so we generate the vectors
and we have n dimensional space of those
vectors and every object is present
somewhere in this space so that at the
query time when we have a new picture we
can map it also in the same way whether
with the same pre-trained neural network
to get its vector representation and
then by finding its nearest neighbors we
are able in a very simple way to find
similar vectors here we tested several
architectures to compare the results of
mean reco and as it turns out ResNet its
resident 50 actually surpassed the other
methods of VG 16 rvg 19 and as expected
I think object detection step improved
the the reco a lot so this these results
are for reco of the exact object that
was present in the room so as a query we
get let's say a chair present here that
was that was taken as a picture and as a
result we say that this is the picture
of this chair but in a catalog on white
background and for extracting visual
features we squeezed Kerris and well and
it is also quite easily done out of the
box you can you can apply a resident 50
model which was for training on image
net and you can even add a parameter for
non including the top layer after we've
extracted all the visual features we
want it of course to test whether this
approach is working on our data set and
to this end we visualized this
international space in resonance it's
two dimensional space so all the image
vectors are two dimension 2000
dimensional and we met them using TC
just to do them
to be able to check whether similar
items are indeed appearing close
together and it turn out that yes as
expected some shapes are preserved as
well as colors have preserved items that
that shares patterns or some colors or
some textures our attempt to really
appear together then as the second step
we decided to add text element to our
search engine as described before we
wanted to be able to search for things
multimodal ease so not only with images
bad with text as well and for text the
standard approach is actually using word
to back and training it on descriptions
that was the most straightforward way of
using that but we bet apart from
training quarter back on product
descriptions we also train it on
contacts so here we assumed as in
regular work to back you have words that
appear in sentences here we assumed so
okay we have rooms rooms are sentences
and furniture objects are our words so
as some words are appearing more
frequently some words are less frequent
we did the same with the different
furniture appearing and different rooms
after training this model we also wanted
to be able to validate it and here we
also apply data sneaked dimensionality
reduction to visualize the the resulting
space of furniture Tyvek and we noticed
that without training it that with that
after training it without any textual
information it tended to catch some
classes quite well so rooms from the
same categories such as baby room or
kitchen tended really clustered together
worried as a dining room or living room
they were really mixed out so that was
as expected so to summarize this the
first framework that we used it worked
that first when given a rooms in image
it
uses different detected objects on that
image and then for every detected object
it gets a set of visually similar
results on the other hand when given a
text query it produces closest furniture
description vectors and closest
furniture embedding vectors then we
blend the results to be able to produce
a final set of the stylistically similar
results so here we tried several
branding approaches one of them was just
to take top K results from each of the
modality and the second approach was to
use features of visual feature
similarity blending so after getting a
set of initial results from each of the
modes we rank them based on visual
similarity to the query and then getting
all the results in the end and now is
the difficult step because how can we
evaluate how can we evaluate if our
models actually working fine
whether one blending method is working
better than the other for this we didn't
want to try the human laborers as said
before so we actually kind of created
our similarity metric well there is a
math formula but this is actually
nothing really fancy this is just an
empirical probability of two items
belonging together in the same room
which is normalized by the maximum
amount of times each of the items
appeared in the rooms overall so after
using this metric we were able to
compute the similarity result for some
example text queries and it turned out
that feature similarity blending worked
the best so this is the one that we rank
the results with visual similarity to
the query after having the initial
results we thought okay this is cool we
have some blending method which works on
textual and image results there are some
initial results but could we create
framework that would learn and to end so
that it would learn a general
presentation of image and text at the
same time for this we turned to
literature because of course we didn't
want to intense a wheel and the most
general approach to creating a
multimodal embedding is to train a semi
SNAT work with image net image branch
and text branch so this is an example
which was done for fashion product
retrieval and the way that authors
created the multimodal space was to use
contrast to floss by generating positive
and negative pairs so here a positive
pair is image of clothing item and
corresponding text exclusion to that
item on the other hand we have a
negative pair which is the same image
but with a non corresponding textual
description so the way that same each
network works with contrast flaws is we
try to maximize the distance between non
corresponding vectors and to minimize
the distance between corresponding
vectors so here what is used also work
to vector processing on the input text
to create a 500 dimensional worked leg
descriptor where a while image is also
pre processed through a pre trained
neural network it's alex net in this
case to get image descriptor what is
done additionally is classification is
applied to each of the branches so that
some semantic information is preserved
so we don't only want to have similar
items from the same image and text
description to be close together but we
also want to vote those networks to
learn that ok this is a skirt this is a
shirt as an example of the of this paper
out authors have done for the fashion
however this is we tried this by adding
the image descriptor and text descriptor
but the results were not very promising
perhaps the reason for that
that this network was worth was built in
purpose to retrieve images when given
text and to retrieve text when given
images and we wanted to do something
quite different we wanted to retrieve
items that with both image and text the
other the other model which we which we
kind of analyzed was unifying visual
semantic embeddings and this model was
used to generate captions for given
images so this is also kind of popular
topic right now in machine learning
visual question answering generating
captions for images or answering
questions about images so here what we
need is so here the author's proposed
CNN LST encoder and CS nom decoder and
we're actually only interested in the
first part where they create a multi
model space because they claimed they
claimed to preserve semantics semantics
regularities so what this means is that
some relationships happen between
vectors so if we take a vector of a car
of a white car and we add a vector for
black then as a result they said that
they would get a black car and we tried
this and there is also actually kind of
promising because when we train the
model on our small IKEA data set which
was composed of only a few thousand
pictures so we actually find film this
we kept some layers frozen and it turned
out that when given a picture of table
and the text query glass it produced
some tables with glass elements and the
second is actually kind of interesting
because when given a picture of a chair
it and a text query white table it
actually produced some weird table ish
furnitures with wheels so it actually
realized that there are some wheels in
this picture
so yeah as a final slide there is a
short demo from our web app where users
can just get a design from the gallery
and then find matching items similar
items as well as items from different
categories that will be matching them
this will be it and now it's your turn
does it okay we have quite time for
questions shucks
okay that's a great presentation I had a
question about the results that you get
does it produce a probability you know
like the the percentage of matching
qualities when you get the results you
know you get six tables there can it
sort by oh you know I think this is 95%
accurate whereas the sixth table is you
know as like fits 50 percent of the
qualities of a you know white table or
something okay so yeah we actually
didn't didn't give a metric for that so
we didn't analyze that we just tried the
results so what we did what we did was
more like median rank so we analyzed
like if there is a similar item which is
it when right when it is presented in
the ranked results but yeah we could do
that of course as well
just wondering for the API are you guys
using tensorflow serving or mysterious
as to how you're using the model life so
we're just building our models and
tensorflow in Karis and Karis mainly and
as I said like when he when we used to
yellow we had to wrap it up but as we
are using tensorflow and Karis for
feature extraction then we decided to go
with this object detection but yeah we
were just training our models on top of
that yeah so the question was is it
published on that github so yeah it is I
didn't include that link so you can
email me and yeah I'll I'll write back
do you categorize them like modern Belle
Epoque or that that kind of categories
to when you're looking at them yes so
that's that actually would be one of the
goals like to be able to one present it
let's say well the picture of table to
be able to add adjectives like vintage
or modern and to retrieve the results
that would be like matching this image
and the text query so this is the final
goal that we are trying to achieve and
then what do you do with like specific
period furnitures that have a name like
Chippendale or Tiffany's or stuff like
that like how do you approach that when
you're putting that in there so right
now we didn't approach that yet so it
really depends on the database so two
booths ability to build our prototype we
didn't have enough of data to be able to
test that we also tried on fashion but
on fashion yeah that's a different topic
anybody else have any questions oh I
just had a question around maybe an
alternative approach and just curious
have you tried that kind of around with
which she was just asking where like you
might have trouble labeling things you
know modern or vintage but if you had a
picture
that was considered modern and you start
matching against it
I would think there'd be something there
so my question is have you looked in
this sort of generating just modern
pictures or anything with like a
generative adversarial net and then
using those somewhere in the pipeline
yes actually that was also one of the
ideas which is also popular in fashion
so a lot of the things in interior
design come from fashion because there
is a lot more research and this is a
very interesting approach
that we thought about doing as well but
we didn't have the time to approach that
so as you say it would be yeah if we
have like we had some pictures that
could that were labeled as modern and
then we could generate different kind of
objects from that we could find for we
look for similar ones yeah thanks I have
one more what do you do with pieces of
furniture that are multi-use that can
change from like a table to a chair like
how do you approach that because we're
talking IKEA here right yeah well
fortunately or no the data centers we
scoped didn't have those but but yeah
actually for the labeling of the
categories so that later when we
retrieved items from specific categories
we used the descriptions that are
available on their website so they have
actually labeled a table chairs table or
chairs so it depends on that cool thank
you
anybody else and final questions thanks
so much
Ivana thanks
[Applause]